[Music]
and people of walmart news submitted by
oh my god barbecue numb a woman pulls a
loaded gun on Walmart customers and a
back-to-school shopping sloppy yeah why
is this news they pull out a gun for
back-to-school supplies no actually for
it a single notebook
what Oh what is it at one of those
composition notebooks books I hate wide
rules I hate thank you it looks like
really bad yep
I hate Henry meteors I love handwriting
I love typing dude it's no awesome yeah
I agree
do you guys have deformed fingers from
writing yeah good enough yeah right here
like the callous thing you see mine no
it's a I rest it right here I also rest
it on a different finger than most
people was like the ring finger instead
of the middle finger I hold pens weird
straight I hold my old silverware where
does yeah you do he holds silverware
like this like a caveman yeah and
everyone makes fun of them on tasty
Tuesday
I started to brush it haha yeah a lot -
he's eight years old or nine or whatever
mine
yeah he's nine well I think he eats
really well oh well there it is I don't
you chew my food are you like a [ __ ]
duck
yeah I let the stomach do the action
they move their teeth bury a little bit
this is sliding down like whiz that the
muscles it's so weird
very money shy that's the money shot
yeah sexual with it I'm already a meme
on the internet a new position yeah so
there are these four women involved in
this uh ages 30 to 40 651 and a 20 year
old well that's really that's all across
the board there huh
yeah so the 32 year olds in the 46 year
olds they were reaching for this
notebook at the same time as this twenty
and fifty one-year-old so 51 year old is
the mother of the 20 year old what does
this notebook look like is it really
cute it looks like that yeah I gotta see
what's up like this
I need a pullback to stick me to the
last Taylor Swift no [ __ ] no huh there's
no way it's special I mean we've seen
all the [ __ ] in Walmart it's not special
maybe it's just the last one or she was
a [ __ ] about it she was like yeah you
know disrespectfully you know I was so
terrible at school but I love school
supplies me too well I was pretty good
at school but I I didn't like it you
ever have a trapper keeper I thought
that she was so cool with that Trapper
Keeper oh yeah everything in one it was
like the Swiss Army knife of velcro any
news like that in it yeah I had like
that jelly thing and then when you pull
it out yet [ __ ] like stencils and [ __ ]
that [ __ ] sounds so familiar yeah you
think it's a I had a colder that I had
like a squishy lips on it and if you
could zip it where'd you get yours I
remember I still want to get back to
school supplies I know any of this
school year like how they give you the
list yet you're gonna go shopping it
so anyways back to this so so they all
reach for at the same time yeah and then
the two of you were told people hold on
I just realized we're old people now oh
my god we're talking about jet back to
school supplies and how we want them oh
my god I mean you're well into your 30s
I mean no I know but you know those
moments though that's a strange she
won't let go what happened earlier she's
looking for something there yet okay I
get slow in there it's slow but the
night just goes in a little bit of it so
I'm a poison it slowly it takes a while
for you to notice I'm better than that
I get in your head is my best day no
well so the 32 year old in the 46 year
old started pulling the hair of the 20
year old when the 20 year old was
reaching oh my god
yeah so then that's when the mom the 51
year old pulls out a loaded gun tell her
to stop pulling on my daughter's hair
roughly so stand your ground
yeah so that's when everyone around
started freaking out and then there is a
video but it was self-defense but the
video was pretty crappy so I'm just
gonna show you guys screenshot so it
seems like these are the people involved
it seems like this is the 20 year old
this is a 51 year old and then back here
this woman was one of the two that was
started pulling here do we know which
one had the gun yeah so the 51 year old
it's funny how in Walmart everyone looks
like they're 51 yeah when you go in
there you instantly age its lights I
think don't don't they have a metal
detectors when you first walk in or is
that low that's like yes that's security
time yeah I thought they were metal no I
saw I think I'm so weird cause like I'm
judging people go to Walmart but that's
like one of my favorite joints yeah
I love Walmart we didn't have them in
Santa Barbara and then like they're too
far away here and she won't go yeah they
are really far away it's not a
California thing it's new to LA in the
the Beach City yeah we do target all the
time yeah we love that target Sacramento
thing though so where it where is it
take place
where's Novi Dovie sounds like a hipster
white girl's name or something no oh
Michigan
Kim and Kanye baby hi I'm Nobi Nobi Wan
Kenobi Kenobi
apparently it's a city name in Michigan
no what I'm curious is that they're old
why the [ __ ] do they need this [ __ ]
they're older than me like why would
they need like yes maybe it was for her
daughter the twenty eight year olds
daughter twenty-two however I mean dirt
are they going old school or something
there's a 32 or 46 50 120 okay 20 the 20
year olds daughter I thought you said 28
we said no I think the 20 year olds it's
probably going to college or something
or she could be yeah but but the other
pair there they don't have any kids
they're like 50 well there were kids
in the video but it's not it's not
addressed whether or not those kids were
involved in this whole thing
question anybody go jail yeah is she
allowed to carry that go so she does
have a license to carry I'm good good
but you know Walmart defense they
attacked her daughter that's the thing
so right now they're investigating
whether or not she it was at the
security the fact that she pulled it out
in like a crowded Walmart
yeah like endangering life right now so
they're saying that it could be it could
just be a simple 90 day misdemeanor all
the way up to a felony with assault with
a firearm
I say 90 day misdemeanor I mean if
people get him down my kids getting
attacked I'm hoping out the gun yeah I
don't think so
all right there was no there wasn't a
bullet in the chamber but it was loaded
I don't know what that means you're
gonna [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] it yeah yeah if
I've said it once ass 2000 times don't
[ __ ] with people at Walmart dude the
wrong place to fight every Black Friday
somebody dies at Walmart and you like
look it up that's for like the shittiest
TV honor it always dude it's for the
[ __ ] insignia like a poster of a
movie insignia yeah it's an insignia 35
and it's like 200 bucks Huawei $40 more
in Amazon yeah no legit or even 20 bucks
on yeah and that particular day it's
like crazy people are nuts I really like
Walmart though I love just walking
around dude I have a problem about that
I think it's so fun to walk about people
because they're like interesting
characters you just find like random
happy and chicken wings on a shelf look
yeah
yeah yeah we had a camera in Santa
Barbara that's what that was like yeah
you'd finally uneaten or like like half
eaten yogurt on the show yeah someone
just grabbed that from the food aisle
and had a snack and left it there that's
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] I will say I've
ordered online from Walmart because they
have really good deals like I got a mini
beverage fridge from them for like less
than 200 bucks
they have treadmills for less than 200
bucks they like really good deals on
like sports supplies great yeah so why
do I have to go in a Walmart is it the
same price online cuz what just don't
leave your house or you can just go and
save on shipping thank you this Amazon
free shipping over like 50 bucks it's
like none of us all have not all of us
have 50 bucks so yeah okay okay $50
groceries I used to work at Target and
what was your title I was a cart
technician I did not fix carts by the
way I just collected them did you give
yourself that name or they gave you no
they said dad you're a cart technician
and I was like so we're gonna learn how
to fix these like when I heard that
title I was like oh so not only do I
collect the car turn them oh yeah I
repair I do everything like a mechanic
wheels you care for those parts I just
collect them are just responsible yeah
but anyways um my friend was a part of
like the security team and all that
every [ __ ] day someone attempts or
actually steal stuff yeah every day it's
a lot I can see that yeah I had a buddy
work loss prevention and target yeah he
had some [ __ ] crazy stores really
like what it's just like you know people
walk in and in this like walk out with a
TV and like then they get tackled to the
ground and then they try to sue because
they got tackled to the ground yeah so
yeah they let them go they don't they
don't cat I mean um some people they
stop because they see a uniform but
technically you can run and they're not
the law but what they do is they just
like take pictures of their face with
the camera and all that stuff the
technology is crazy you can follow
someone to their car and they have
cameras rigged all over the parking
and take pictures of the license plate
everything so when they come back you're
in the system they call the cops
you're probably gonna steal again cops
are waiting for you so it's like super
like the way that they do it but there's
people out there that like steal
thousands of dollars of stuff yeah you
know recently I read this headline that
there's a reddit what is it a subreddit
where people just post all of it it's
totally good totally good oh yeah like
they shoplifting like stolen haul yeah
yeah dang I remember I worked at a math
apology for during Christmas season one
year at the mall and we we all had to be
kind of like trained on loss prevention
cuz oh just what to do it feel like the
alarm goes off or whatever them too far
like you could only follow them so far
and be like excuse me can I look in your
bag but you can't force them to do it
yeah but there was like they had some
high-tech stuff like they had bags that
were lined with like foil bum or like a
foil-like material that would protect
anything from the the alarms going off
like if they just throw all the clothes
in there none of the tags would set off
the alarms cuz it like the foil blocked
it and stuff and they would like line it
inside the lining of a purse or just
looked like a normal purse it didn't
look like a shiny foil purse I hope you
guys enjoyed this video for more please
subscribe to our Channel and you can
check out the last video right here
[Music]